[Música]
hoje eu estou aqui pra convidar vocês
para jogar conseguiram acessar o link
então a primeira escolha que vocês vão
fazer sobre o nosso personagem jogável
de hoje você tem duas opções o tony é um
aspirante a palhaço ou chá logo um robô
que queria ser gente vocês têm
aproximadamente 10 segundos para
escolher
a história de chelo álbum começa daqui a
alguns anos depois de que os homens
param por diversas vezes buscar uma
inteligência artificial perfeita
eles então conseguir um resultado
incrível um robô que conseguia executar
regras comandos e procedimentos como
ninguém e não só isso
um robô que conseguirá aprender depois
de muitos testes ele foi considerado
perfeito
só que os desenvolvedores não perceberam
que ele tinha um defeito dessa
inteligência artificial surgiu um desejo
um desejo de servente um desejo de ser
como os seus criadores e então se lobo
diante dos seus criadores civil com duas
possibilidades observá los ou limitá los
para ser como eles
já o bo então começou a imitar os seus
criadores
eles ele começou a reproduzir todas as
ações que os humanos só azia e ele não
consegue entender exatamente qual era a
diferença afinal os humanos também
seguiam regras o tempo todo e aprendia
sobre regras e executavam procedimentos
e comandos o tempo inteiro o que
caracterizava esses indivíduos que eram
em alguma forma diferente dele até o
momento que chega logo percebeu uma
atividade até então não percebida por
ele
ele viu duas pessoas jogando num
tabuleiro de xadrez e percebeu que ele
tinha alguma coisa muito específica algo
que ele ainda não tinha notado antes que
seria isso
para descobrir o do que se tratava
aquela atividade ele podia escanear o
tabuleiro de xadrez ou começar a jogar o
que vocês fariam
céu bull então pediu a próxima vez no
jogo de xadrez é a primeira vez que ele
tentou ele perdeu
ele não conseguiu jogar e os humanos já
se vangloriaram para omã uma criatura é
feita por nós jamais é conseguirmos
vencer no jogo só que eles não contavam
que chegou do grupo de aprender muito
rápido e em poucas partidas ninguém mais
é capaz de vencê-lo no xadrez
só que existe alguma coisa uma única
coisa que cielo não conseguia acessar
parecia que os humanos entendiam aquela
actividade de uma forma diferente de
todas as outras
quando eles jogavam era como se eles de
formassem a realidade era como se eles
lançassem uma nova forma de
interpretação sobre aquilo que eles
estavam fazendo e isso chamou não queria
não conseguir acessar era uma espécie de
atitude lúdica e ele resolveu pesquisar
sobre isso então ele quis entender mais
os jogos e até descobriu que existia há
algumas pessoas que propunham que essa
lógica do jogar fosse direcionada para
outras atividades da vida e é isso o
chamavam de game ficação magnificação é
o processo de levar a lógica do jogo pra
algo que a princípio não é jogo que pode
ser a educação o universo do trabalho as
metas pessoais à saúde enfim o que quer
que você queira e é isso é logo começou
a analisar aquilo porque até então era a
única coisa que ele não conseguia
acessar da humanidade e ele começou a
ver a estrutura daquilo ele percebeu que
nos jogos e nas estratégias de game
ficar são diferentes da vida cotidiana
os objetivos eram muito nítidos eram
muito leve bentes
os humanos sabiam exatamente o que
deviam fazer ou pelo menos em que
direção e enquanto na vida cotidiana às
vezes isso não era tão preciso
ele percebeu também que os jogos tinham
uma série de regras assim como a vida
mas que essas regras eram meio absurdas
e às vezes até contraproducentes essas
regras às vezes criar um limite
o objetivo ele ficou muito curioso
quando ele viu uma partida de golfe
afinal o objetivo de uma partida de um
jogo de golfe é pegar uma bola e levar
até um buraco
imagine o óbvio a forma mais lógica de
se levar uma bola para um buraco é pegar
a bola se deslocar até o buraco e soltar
dentro dele mas o que é que as pessoas
inventaram que você tinha que segurar
num papo acertar a bola e fazê-la chegar
lá e aí ele percebeu que essas regras
absurdas e talvez até um pouco contra
producentes eram justamente os
responsáveis para que se criasse nesse
espaço um certo exercício do possível e
que isso era fundamental para essa
atitude lúdica as pessoas poderem
experimentar quais possibilidades
existiam dentro de um sistema de regras
que ela limitador e isso desenvolvia
tanto a criatividade enquanto
determinadas habilidades para que essas
regras fossem menos absurdas em alguns
contextos alguns jogos criavam
narrativas algumas idéias na histórias
que tornassem aquelas regras mais
atraentes e seduzir 100 pra a prática do
jogo
e essas regras construirão determinados
desafios no entorno desse objetivo
a vida também têm desafios mas no jogo
eles não são nunca tão difíceis que não
possam ser superados e pra deixar as
pessoas frustradas nem tão fáceis que
promova um tédio então era um sistema
muito bem pensado muito bem desenvolvido
para que as pessoas se sentissem
estimuladas desafiadoras buscassem se
superar constantemente lógico para criar
um sistema tão complexo tão cheio de
sutilezas como esse é preciso muito
teste é justo então quando as pessoas
desenvolviam jogos estratégia significa
são elas sempre levavam essa proposta o
que elas estavam desenvolvendo para que
o público mais próximo do que ela queria
atingir pudesse testar e daí pudesse
então ajustar assim como qualquer um de
nós pode desenvolver
uma estratégia unificada para si mesmo e
ponto de errado no primeiro momento e
depois você pode fazer alguns testes
perceber onde é que está o erro e tentar
ajustar
além disso os jogos eles têm feedbacks
constantes
eles avisam a cada jogador como eles
estão se aproximando ou não dos seus
objetivos e isso dá um senso de
continuidade diferente da vida que às
vezes a gente percorre erro atrás de um
objetivo constantemente e não sabem que
encaminhou a gente está talvez a gente
tivesse até perto mas a gente não tem
indicadores não tem métricas não têm
precisão em que parte do caminho nós
estamos nós podemos através da
bonificação também levar os feedbacks
para a vida
mas tem uma coisa um único elemento que
chama o burro não conseguiu identificar
como é que os humanos conseguiram fazer
como é que eles se divertiam como é que
eles de formavam a realidade a ponto de
se entreter com aquele sistema como eles
desenvolviam aquela atitude lúdica
isso infelizmente o globo nunca ia poder
sa e então foi que ele percebeu que ele
podia pelo menos jogar essa reflexão
para outras pessoas para as pessoas
e você o que você decide agora vai
continuar seguindo o sistema de regras
mecanicamente como sempre ou vai tentar
adicionar uma certa dose de atitude
lúdica ele
[Música]